ce premier reportage nous a mis en
appétit suivons le guide
un peu plus loin cent soixante cinq
salles nouvelle douze mille objets dans
ce bâtiment second empire l' aile
richelieu de legs de le des musées du
monde le louvre s'embellit de 21 8 500
m² taillé sur mesure pour les oeuvres
verrière perché à 25 mètres fini
l'entassement bonjour l'espace les vrais
chevaux de marie galope dans cet ancien
parking des finances la cour marly 2000
mètres carrés de lumière blonde en la
réussite c'est d'avoir réussi à faire
pénétrer par exemple ici le soleil est
effectivement être évités cette
impression de candide frigidaire du
coffre-fort un petit peu froid quand
certains musées il ya le fond et la
forme et que nous espérons c'est que les
visiteurs ont pas une idée par l'al
l'importance pas de du bâtiment par tant
par son immensité mai
viendront et reviendront ça c'est notre
but essentiel c'est que de donner le
goût aux visiteurs de devenir des
familiers du lourd un des fidèles du
musée ultime coup de brosse sur des
ongles coulée dans le bronze
ces captifs magnifique dans le style à
part à de louis xiv renforcer la gloire
de la statue du roi soleil place des
victoires avant la révolution
milon de crotone emménagent ces trois
mètres cinquante de marbre chef-d'oeuvre
du grand sculpteur qui honore de son nom
la cour puget talents français 17e 19e
mercure de plomb de l'illustre sculpteur
pigalle qui accepte mal les paillettes
tristounette de son quartier
des portraits qui nous regardent
éclairage intimiste digne des cabinets
et des secrets de la renaissance pure
merveille française signée cloué ou
corneille de lyon
m
la grosse banquière surnom
irrévérencieux de marie de médicis a
commencé les collections du louvre
cet éclairage nouveau le système génital
utilisant mieux la lumière de jour
aurait plu à la reine qui a demandé à
rubens de retracer sa vie saga sur toile
24 tableaux sargon ii roi d'assyrie -700
évocation gigantesque d'un palais bâti
pour impressionner le client avec cette
fabuleuse cours corse abad cinq taureaux
ailés jusqu'à 5 m et 38 tonnes
chrysalide louve métamorphosé en
papillon tgl très grand loup vitrine
encyclopédique
il me semble le disait cézanne qu'il ya
tout dans le louvre que l'on peut tout
aimé tout comprendre par lui le songe
s'animer proform l'écrin vient de
s'ouvrir
l'oeil en brie déjà de plaisir